what's behind the latest military coup
in burkina faso the president is
arrested as soldiers mutiny against the
government's failure to stop attacks by
armed groups what's required to restore
stability this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
imran khan it's the african country
where military coups happen all too
often in the latest attempt in burkina
faso the internet is down and the main
tv station's under military control and
soldiers say they've detained president
roshi kabul
[Music]
tension escalated on sato when security
forces fought with protesters who blamed
the government for failing to stop
attacks by armed groups on sunday
soldiers mutinied at military bases in
the capital wagodugu and two other
cities the leaders of the revolt made
six demands including the replacement of
military commanders and better equipment
to fight armed groups
some protesters showed their support in
street demonstrations the defense
minister went on tv to deny a coup
attempt and the government imposed a
curfew nicholas hack is to monitoring
developments for us from dhaka in
senegal
there are celebrations in the capital
wakaduku and across the country many
saying that president mccabe had it
coming he was seen as weak and
inefficient in the face of growing
attacks from armed groups linked to isil
and al-qaeda and the tipping point
happened in november where security
forces almost 50 of them died in the
region of inata and there was public
outcry when it turned out that not only
were they ill-equipped but they had gone
weeks without receiving their food
rations president
marquez was seen as a president that was
not
equipping the soldiers sent on the front
line without their food rations and so
there were protests across burkina faso
and those protests were clamped down um
president rockman cover made a series of
measures dismissing his government
several times most recently dismissing
several senior officers some of them
were arrested allegedly plotting a coup
against him and so it seems now that
they the military are now in charge of
burkina faso this may be a step back for
democracy in a region that has seen
three coups one in guinea the other in
mali and now in burkina faso but for
many in the country it's seen as a step
forward for better security more than
1.5 million people have been displaced
and over 2 000 people have been killed
in a country on the verge of chaos
despite the support of french forces
that are on the ground
nicholas hawk al jazeera for inside
story
we'll introduce our panel in just a
moment but first let's take a quick look
at how we got here
now as nicholas hack mentioned attacks
linked to iceland al-qaeda have killed
thousands and displaced around one and a
half million people
the military has been suffering losses
since the violence began in 2016. last
december more than 50 security forces
were killed in the north
the continued killing of civilians
triggered demonstrations against the
government
military leaders also complained about a
lack of equipment and training
in october president rosh cabore
replaced the chiefs of the army and the
air force to quell discontent within the
military
and earlier this month a dozen soldiers
were arrested on suspicious of
conspiring against the government
let's bring in our guests in accra the
capital of ghana emmanuel kwesienning
director of research of the kofi nan
international peacekeeping training
center in uppsala in sweden yes
berbianison senior researcher at the
nordic africa institute and from
casablanca in morocco adama gay a
journalist author and former director of
information at equest that's the
economic community west african states
welcome to you all i'd like to begin in
casablanca uh in morocco with you adama
gay uh president rosh kabal has seen the
writing on the wall for a long time in
fact he did arrest senior military
leaders but that's seemingly not enough
to stop a coup from happening how much
trouble is he in
oh he's in big trouble because this was
as you rightly said
writings on the wall
people were not happy with him the
civilian in the country but also the
military they were not happy and you
remember in november last year 14
november 53
burkina bay jandar
were killed in a town called
inata and the military complained that
they didn't have even ammunition and
food for themselves so the president
then decided to reshuffle his government
to change his minister of defense
and to even take charge himself but this
was too little and too late and indeed
uh there was really a race towards his
toppling just two weeks ago there was an
attempt to tap on him by
learner colonel jugrana
this gentleman was arrested and put
in control by the military
as he was until yesterday but
people including a colleague of years uh
decided to strike yesterday through a
missionary
by expressing their discontent
towards the president of burkina faso
and progressively as people cheers to
them
in the city
not just of
kaija and elsewhere they
felt emboldened and later despite the
victory
of burkina faso at the african cup of
nation leading it to the steam to the uh
quarter-final the military said that
this was the opportunity for them to fix
forever this problem because they are
praised that mr rock mark cavalry was
somehow a lame tech president unable to
under the security challenges he was not
really very strong and he didn't deliver
the results that people expected him to
bring to his country ever since he
became president in 2015. well let's
let's make that point uh to emanuel uh
kwesi anning um
burkina faso has a unique perhaps more
than any other african nation uh problem
when it comes to fighting al qaeda and
isil indeed a couple years ago on isil
message boards there was talk that they
wanted to make burkina faso the capital
of the new caliphates that never
happened but the fighting has been tough
for burkina faso does the army
in the kino faso have a point they're
not equipped to fight this fight and
this is why they've mounted this action
well i mean i think the army does have a
point but it's not just about the lack
of appropriate
and adequate logistics it's also about
the doctrine
it's about the leadership
it's about the nature of the messaging
and understanding of
of the enemy that they are trying to
resist
armies work best when there's clear
political leadership with a message
that
you know that drives the army
and
and ensures that their actions are
it i think that political leadership
of leading
of oversight
of control of ensuring
that the structures themselves within
the army function effectively to be able
to take on this enemy
has been weak leading
to the army itself
creating atrocities or committing
atrocities
that has led the army to lose some of
the support from the
populace the failure to establish a
caliphate
for me it's the temporary reversal
there's something
of the bokina government
well let me take that let me take that
point to our next guest uh yes janasen
uh who is in uppsala in sweden
are we at a stage where the president is
actually afraid of his own military he
was afraid that they were becoming too
powerful so he didn't give them
what they needed to fight that fight and
now they're actually put him under house
arrest his back his strategy is almost
backfired because he was afraid of them
in the first place
well i think it is a very tricky sort of
um
structure to maneuver for the president
and that will be true of any president
uh succeeding cabaret if that is what
we're seeing now uh we have to
distinguish first of all of course
between the troops actually fighting the
war against jihadism in the north of the
country and then the central military
leadership and as mr gay said there has
been some replacements now in the
military leadership but i still heard
soldiers protesting yesterday calling
for
another change of the head of the army
not of the president so i think
uh first of all we have to nuance our
understanding of what the the different
factions of the army actually are asking
for and then we also have to distinguish
between the military elite and and sort
of the troops themselves um i think uh
the president's challenge has been that
he has as far as i've understood he has
appointed
uh new leadership within the armed
forces now that seemed to be sort of
a group formerly referred to as le boys
who were loyal to
the state uh during the attempted coup
of 2015 and he may have sort of
marginalized other actors within the
armed forces that are now reacting to
not being as more central to power so
it's a very complicated structure and a
very complicated game the president has
had to play there
adam again would you agree that
factionalism within the army is a big
driver of what we're seeing there is
this army in the north that isn't very
happy with the central army leadership
as our guest has just pointed out would
you say that that's true
yeah that's true and
also this is compounded by the fact that
there is literally
a division in terms of advantages
given to what we can consider the
mexican general in the army
we have been benefiting from the
resources of the state whether the lower
rank people who took actually the coup
and did it yesterday
didn't benefit from it so this is a
reality but beyond that i think the
country was not properly managed
before mr khabar came to power for
almost 27 years after the
demise of thomas sankara in october 1987
is killing by the people surrounding the
former president of blesco paore
the country for 27 years somehow
with compromisions deals made with the
jihadists and terrorist forces
by mr compower the previous president
they managed to
literally stabilize and put away burkina
faso from the countries that were
affected by this
plague of
jihadism and terrorism but now uh what
has happened
ever since mr uh
rock cabori by the way who is a former
really powerful person within the
compound regime but managed to change
gear and become a reinvented democrat
ever since they came
in the problems they have been
multiplying you have 1.5 million
burkinabe people who live as displaced
people within the country you have uh
funnily in the country you have economic
difficulties and the military is this
disgruntled all these things have
compounded the problem and made it
untenable from mr rockeford i know
personally mr cabrini for many years
he's a gentleman but he's not the type
of leader strong leader that the mr
gentleman from akara said who can devise
a clear policy that the military would
follow he was right really playing ticks
to make sure that anybody who is
empowered in the military would be loyal
to him when we know that most of the
military they were somehow
groomed under the previous president mr
koppel
uh ekawas have just come out with some
statements quite crucial statements
actually they've describing it as an
attempted coup uh they've also said that
the army is responsible for the physical
integrity of rosh uh kaburi himself and
ekowas have also said
that they want to see rapid change uh in
the situation um is anybody going to be
listening to echoes emmanuel kwesienning
well i mean this sounds very much like
like a repetition um of the same
statements with respect to mali with
respect to
guinea and abu kina faso i think the
primary element here
are the democratic reversals the
inability
of those who
govern
to really have a handle on the
multiplicity
of problems that their country has
and for echoers to play
that intervening mediatory role
of nudging its leaders towards a more
inclusive open
dialogic form of governance so there
wouldn't be much listening because look
the demographics on the subregion have
changed you know people are increasingly
becoming impatient
they are demanding
governance that that speaks to the
challenges that they face on a daily
basis and both adam and bianda have told
us quite a lot about the realistic
day-to-day challenges of people and i
think
west africa's political leadership
including echo as his leadership
must be sensitive
to the driving forces
of the majority of these people in the
sub region poorly educated unemployed no
housing for health benefit and
increasingly unemployable and frustrated
but with
with sophisticated foods to know what is
happening elsewhere and this dichotomy
of living in extreme poverty
and non-functioning societies
whilst knowing what their counterparts
elsewhere are having
right let me bring that point to jesper
bjarnison echoase is the economic
community of west african states is it
actually a player in this particular
scenario or like i guess it's just said
it's again the statements that we've
heard before and they're not really
resonating with the people the poor on
the ground well i would say that uh if
we look at what's happening in mali i
think ecowas is trying to
um
to to reimpose itself as a relevant
actor uh when it comes to
uh sort of um
in mali trying to to convince the
military junta to to hand over power to
a civilian-led transitional government
uh but it's true that that echoes has
been criticized of being sort of a
president's club where
you know the heads of state of of
countries with questionable uh
democratic records are looking out for
each other rather than looking out for
their populations so i think ecowas has
a legitimacy problem to to deal with but
i do think that these kinds of
statements are necessary as a minimum i
think that not making uh condemning
statements about a potential military
takeover would be even worse so i don't
think there's much else for ecowas to do
at the moment but they will have to work
hard to deserve uh credibility in the
eyes of of west african people in
general i would i would say adam again
the same point to you are echo as a
player right now
no e-commerce
has lost
credibility
uh
takes the case of money the
huge type of sanction they decided
against a country that is almost uh
going down the drain
has been rejected by the population
across
not just west africa but across africa
this is a president's class little
months earlier
they are there just for themselves why
didn't they react when guinea conakry a
president the former president mr alfa
conde was a civilian and he was killing
people uh were demanding democracy
why don't they react when sudanese
people are being killed
leaders they close their eyes on
constitutional civilian coup and now
they are coming trying to maintain to
power people the ordinary citizens do
not like
as a former director of communication of
ecowas and
the change in demographic
with youngsters coming up
knowing what is going on in the world
and they demand an ecowas of the people
not an echoes of the state or a request
of the head of state
so this is something they need to accept
and acknowledge and open up the field of
conversation to make sure that they do
not end up appearing as uttering this
kind of statement that people do not pay
attention to mr rock cabaret has been in
power for almost
six years
and the problem has been worsening well
we'll get into we will get into the
director to
well let's talk about the let's talk
about the other organization before we
get into uh how long the president has
been powerful uh emmanuel quirky ending
where is the african union in all of
this do they have a role to play
i mean they've always had a role to play
but the structure of the relationship
between the african union and its racial
economic communities is that
eco was based on the subsidiarity
principle
becomes the first
regional organization that should
respond to the challenges
that burkina faso has faced and the
african union will take
guidance
from
abuja where a coast is based but they
realize the challenge
and as adam is saying
how do we ensure
that we have institutions that are
responsive
and sensitive to the needs of people now
when you have institutions that are
increasingly reactive
and are not perceived by the generality
of the populace that they lead
as being
understanding and nuanced in their
perception of their problems
then
statements
emanating from these institutions are
perceived to be purely platitude now
burkina faso hasn't happened overnight
we saw equals meetings in accra where
they were focusing on mali
so that gives an impression
that there's a lack of appropriate
intelligence
order
so we seem to have lost emmanuel there
we will come back to you uh yes bibianas
and here we go you have echoes you have
the african union they are players uh
within this entire scenario that's
playing out right now but you also have
a generational problem of corruption of
mismanagement that's taken place that's
led to this anger none of this is
solvable overnight so literally the
future for burkina faso in the next few
months will be a military almost failed
state surely
well let's let's hope for the best i
would say uh let's first see what
happens uh in these coming days uh as
far as i know it hasn't really been
confirmed that this is an in a complete
military takeover uh i would just i
would look back to
uh the the popular uprising of 2014 and
say that even before the regional
jihadist terrorism became such an
imposing problem on burkina faso the
country was facing a very steep uh
transition from the 27-year rule of
blaze compare into a more democratic
state and that challenge was then
compounded by
uh the the sort of the the growing
threat of uh and and menace of of the
jihadist terrorism so
already uh at
that time when uh mr compare came sorry
mr cabrera came into power you know that
was a very steep challenge to face
um
and i don't i think he's been fairly
realistic in the promises he's made to
some extent but of course
any any head of state would would
struggle to keep the promises under
those conditions so what he has failed
at
dramatically is of course communicating
the extent to which those promises were
just not possible to keep
the question of whether we're heading
towards a military state now
i think we should be very careful
about normalizing military rule in the
region i think that's a that's the first
key point there
and i think it's up to all these
different actors regional continental
and international to keep pressure
on any military actor stepping forward
and claiming leadership now i think it's
important that we find a way back to
civilian rule if this is indeed a
military takeover
adama gay our guest has just said we
should not normalize military coups but
there is a scenario maybe that this
might be a good thing because of the
jihadist terrorism uh the jihadist armed
groups that they face in the north of
the country maybe this is what's needed
to defeat those groups and clearly
that's an international objective
doesn't have anything to do with the
people of beginner fafsa and helping
them but it is an international
objective is there
a response here that is actually good
yeah there is a global recession of
democracy uh in the world
the summit on democracy organized
recently by president biden in america
was a failure and many in africa are
looking
to
turkey china russia to strongmen
leading some countries as model to
emulate
now you have also to take into account
the history of uh burkina faso this is
not the first time the military come
into the political frame uh i remember
general lansen
he was a military in his 70s
afterwards there was another military
and then in the 80s there was thomas
sankara who came to power in 1983-84
and then bless comparison was also a
military so this is not something new
in the history of burkina faso the
problem is
you can't call countries
to demand
for civilian rule to be in place when
those civilians rule once they come to
power they interns themselves and only
privatize the resources of their
countries and act for restored interest
not for the common good and this is the
problem
because i remember i was in algiers in
june
1999 when the then
oau the premises of african union
decided to ensure that the military
leave the management of the countries to
allow the civilian but it was against a
deal that the civilian would deliver on
good governance that they will ensure
the physical integrity of the countries
and they will promote good governance of
their resources and democracy this is
not happening and the deal is failing
and don't be surprised
that
more military prompted by african
youngsters and other african public
opinion makers influences
will enter into the political frame
because like the other gentleman said
the african union and other african
organizations they are absent out of the
scene and
united nations organizations do not seem
to understand the challenges proving
within west africa at the moment and
within africa in general uh to say the
least
well thank you very much to all our
guests emmanuel kwesi yes bobby anderson
and adama gay and thank you too for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story and you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me imran khan and
the whole team here in doha bye for now
you